[Music]
thank you
[Music]
well hello there watching The Press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with Kevin McGuire
associate editor of the Daily Mirror and
Kate Ferguson political editor at the
sun on Sunday welcome and great to see
both of you so to the front pages let's
see what's uh making uh the France
referendum Indie bin that is how the
Metro headlines the Supreme Court ruling
that a second Independence referendum in
Scotland can't be held without
permission from Westminster
the eye says that prime minister Rishi
sunak is facing a battle with his own
MPS who are demanding he comes up with
new policies and a clear agenda to take
the party and the country forward
Daily Mail reporting that drivers are
being hit with record numbers of parking
tickets because a promised government
Crackdown on so-called Cowboy parking
operators hasn't happened yet the
guardian leading with claims that a
conservative peer and her family receive
millions of pounds after a personal
protection equipment company was awarded
a government contract during the
pandemic on her recommendation lawyers
for the peer say they can't comment
while an investigation is ongoing
the time says the government is to
launch a massive save energy campaign to
get people to use less power in the face
of rising prices and the pressure on
suppliers from Russia
according to the telegraph GPS who are
failing to see enough patients face to
face are to be named and shamed to try
to reduce the stress on Hospital
Emergency Services
the express has news that a new drug
proven to slow down the advance of
Alzheimer's disease could be available
here next year
Financial Times reporting that
businesses and unions want the
government to scrap its planned bonfire
of EU regulations because it would only
cause more confusion and disruption to
companies and employees
the sun leads with claims by TV
presenter Johnny Irwin that he was
sacked from his job on the show A Place
in the Sun after he told his bosses he
had terminal cancer
well the star can't resist laughing at
Germany's footballers for losing to
Japan at the World Cup
quick reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out those front pages
while you listen to our guests so let us
head to Kevin McGuire associate editor
of the Daily Mirror and Kate Ferguson
political editor at the sun on Sunday
welcome to both of you
um so that Court decision Today front
page of the Metro referendum Indie bin
um you know they're having a bit of a
joke aren't they at that but Nicholas
sturgeon Kevin making quite clear It's
Not Over
yeah I don't know if we're supposed to
use a uh Scottish accent is that what
the Metro means there uh with that uh
that pun but now it was very
unsurprising really because I think the
legislation was clear that it's the the
UK UK government prime minister who
would give the authority uh for another
Scottish referendum but Nikola
sturgeon's playing a political game here
I don't think she ever thought she would
win she might have thought the court
would rule that unless until the sorry
until the draft legislation is fully
published in Scotland there would be no
ruling but you can now say look uh
Westminster England is stopping the
Scottish people having the referendum
they want to the Scottish Parliament
which they elected and she says she'll
make it a big issue at the next general
election attorney in a referendum well
that's going to be dangerous should the
SMP not get more than 50 of the vote in
that election which they never had and
also because Labor's resurgent in
Scotland and under anasawa that gives
them a weigh-in of saying a campaign
look this is about how are you going to
rule Scotland now it's about your
services
that's uh why why don't you vote for
that rather than uh you know this
obsession with independence of a party
which in 2014 said it would be once in a
generation chance and the generations
normally 25 to 30 years because it's
defined as a somebody's born and they
grow up and have children of their own
but it's a big it's a big political
issue particularly in Scotland I mean
there are so many questions that come
from this aren't there um Kate you know
does a vote for the SMP means support
for Independence when we've seen the
collapse of Labor in Scotland and also
we know Nicholas sturgeon is an arch
political strategist you know some
commentators saying she didn't want to
referendum she didn't know she was going
to win it better for the UK government
to say no to it or the courts rather
um than her actually not not have it and
now making the next general election a
one-issue vote means people don't look
at her record on for example education
and health in Scotland
yeah I think anything that detracts with
Scottish people from looking at the SMP
record on public services is probably a
good thing for the SMP I mean in this
case today they've obviously said
Scotland can't go ahead and have an an
indicative referendum without the
permission of parliament but there's
this amazing quote in the Metro Splash
where they where Nicholas Durden says as
long as there is breath in my body I
will carry on with this campaign and as
you say she wants to make the next
general election a sort of referendum a
kind of a proxy referendum I guess on
that we know don't we that the SNP are
going to bang on about this issue
forever and there was absolute Fury from
the SMP benches in pmqs today which
happened just a couple of hours after
this ruling one smpmp after the other
get into their feet accusing London of
blocking the will of the Scots you can
imagine that's all clipped up put it on
their Twitter feed straight away but
Kevin makes a good point which is labor
quite fancy their chances in Scott them
to the next general election they
they're hoping to win I think it's about
a dozen seats across the corridor
um around Glasgow and Edinburgh and if
labor do better at the next general
election in Scotland if the SMP do worse
then will that kind of backfire for
Nicola sturgeon and will that be seen as
a sign that support for Independence is
on the Wane in Scotland that's a danger
for her yes and Rishi sunak will have to
sing from the unionist him she will he
not for the next couple of years he's
also on the front page of the eye Kevin
um Tori MPS are restless already it does
not take them long does it
um housing policies we know we had in
the papers um from this morning are
suggestion that Lots will quit before
the next election
um you name it there's a list there on
the front of the eye
no absolutely look it's it's a party
that possibly doesn't want to be layered
or is incapable of being led anymore and
they both want new policies and then
block the policies that are coming
forward say on housing the vote's being
postponed put into uh into law that
Target 300 000 new homes a year because
Tories and the shires don't want uh new
houses on Greenbelt and their
constituents it's a real NIMBY Instinct
but there's a lot of discontent the the
eye is spoken to quite a few
conservative MPS and you know Kate and I
in the House of Commons you don't get
many many happy conservative MPS at all
you get a fair few labor some still
unhappy it's got to be said but they're
they're happy and it's uh sunax got his
work cut out because he got a terrible
economic Outlook uh going into recession
the biggest squeezing living standards
uh in modern history the tax burden its
highest since the second world war going
in going into recession looks like it'll
be longer than other countries still not
recovered to prepare pandemic levels
unlike the other major economies in the
G7 so you can see there's a lot from
them to be worried about and you know
this week we had a 32 year old I think
yeah I think it was 32 and a
four-year-old conservative MPS and
they're going to quit the next election
I think loads of them will go there's
particular worry about the seats in the
Northeast that part of the red wall
where voters turned off by Jeremy corbyn
gave the conservatives a chance and um I
feel it hasn't hasn't paid off so no
it's it's really unhappy I don't know
what he's going to be able to do
soon act to get this because uh back
back in uh back in good order for him
because
um yeah as I say the economy is bad
living standards are bad inflation's
High wages aren't going up as much as as
prices so all in all it's glum for the
Tories and just just quickly on this
then Kate um the eye suggesting they
need to get policies out of the door
quickly as part of the solution but
every party is a broad church is the
conservative party now unnaturally broad
because they've got the traditional
voters you know you mentioned the shires
Kevin but they've also got that red wall
block you know it's urban areas it's a
different type of of electorate isn't it
yeah I mean there's a big question for
the Tory leader who is now Rishi sunak
Boris had this amazing electoral
Coalition which warned him what in
modern terms is a pretty Landslide
Victory you can get the working class up
north and the Northeast this so-called
red wallers and these pasture Tories now
if Rishi wants to hold that Coalition
together yes he doesn't want to be
battered by back bench revolves but he's
going to lead that Coalition he's got to
still get policy out the door in my
opinion the son's humble opinion he's
got to get give people the chance to own
their own homes so yes it's a fractious
party it's had a history over the past
few years of you know killing their
leaders rebelling revolting but it also
does hanker after leadership so Richie
has to tread carefully but he can't be
bullied by the shy Tories on this okay
um ft
um one of those papers that has the
silent protest of the German team you
know very effective you might argue
Kevin
um as a as many of the teams there
including those European teams that
ended up wanting to wear the rainbow
armband try to find some way of making
their feelings felt
no absolutely they will want a seven one
the one live one band England Wales uh
two of the others this in a way is
probably more effective although you
know their protests there could run
their mouths you know you're not allowed
to speak it just as the uh Iran's team
the players didn't sing their uh their
national anthem because of you know
protests back home and expressing
solidarity with people against pretty
violent and thuggish regime back in
Tehran and both of those Germany and
around lost it's got to be said but I
don't think the protest had anything to
do with it I think it's backfired
completely on FIFA and the uh the Qatari
uh authoritarian anti-homosexual regime
Banning the unbans if it is louder than
it would be worn they would have been
one little comment now it's a huge issue
right around the world and it reflects
badly on FIFA and old guitar okay it's
also on the front page of the Daily
Telegraph
um Kate but so too a suggestion that GPS
really do need to start seeing more
patience is something Telegraph is very
committed to they suggest there should
be a list of Shame
yeah this is this new idea that's coming
into force that GP surgeries will be
named and shamed for how many patients
or What proportion of patients get
offered a face-to-face GP appointment
now this is a story that's been rumbling
along for a few months isn't it post
covered can we get GP appointments at
all but if we want them face to face can
we get in there I remember going to my
own GP surgery after all the lockdown
rules were lifted and the whole GP
surgery was covered in cling film and we
weren't we were allowed one in worn out
it was sort of very bizarre experience
but this is a story about how GPS will
be named and shamed to be on a sort of
League table and you'll get to see how
well your GP is fair and compared to
others now crucially this speaks to a
broader government policy which is they
want to try and introduce more
transparency and more competition within
the NHS in the hope that that will lift
standards and lift patient experiences
they think that's happened well in
schools in education and they want to
try and emulate that in the NHS and
Health Service I think a lot of my
readers probably can't remember the last
time they got offered a face-to-face GP
appointment and this will be pretty
welcome but the true proof will be in
the pudding can people actually get to
see a doctor within time okay we'll
we'll see what happens with that but um
you know no doubt the telegraph will
keep on going with that one lots more to
come including how much would you pay
for a Christmas tree surely not that
much back in a moment
[Music]
thank you
well welcome back you're watching the
Press preview With Me Now Kevin McGuire
from the mirror and Kate Ferguson from
the Sun On Sunday welcome back to both
of you
um to the times uh we briefly go Kevin
got a lot to pack in uh if we all
remember the light touch energy
um initiative of Jacob Reese smog for
some 15 million that was binned by Liz
truss this one is going to be 25 million
pounds a public information campaign to
encourage people to reduce their energy
bills by turning down boilers radiators
Etc what do you think
yeah well let's hope it's not too little
too late no I think it's a good idea you
might think to say a lot of it is common
sense but people just don't know and
just need some encouragement The
Government Can See bills are soaring uh
and uh you know people are going to be
hit hard bills will go up again uh next
April when the cap will be raised by
another 500 pounds so so I really do
think it's quite sensible you could turn
off lights on some public buildings as
well uh I think I think we can all save
money and we're gonna we can all help
out it might avoid power Cuts but it's a
shame the government is a dividend
dallied and taken this long to agree the
campaign well certainly they uh the time
says Jeremy Hunt
um has said all households had a
responsibility to cut energy use by as
much as 15 to stop Britain from being
blackmailed by President Putin and the
times has been told about false a
full-scale public information campaign
led by ministers celebrities uh adverts
Etc so a bit different from the light
touch of Mr MOG possibly but to the Ft
um Kate lots of Liz truss period
dwelling here the guilt crisis was a big
factor in this fear about the UK Pension
funds the 500 billion pound hit to
Pension funds
yeah I mean so much has happened in
politics over the last couple of months
but Castle remains back about I think
about four weeks ago or a bit further
maybe when Liz truss was pm and the mini
budget sent those markets into Mayhem
and you had this
um this run on the guilt market now
without wanting to get overly technical
what this basically did was wipe a bunch
of value off the price of Pension funds
and the Ft has been given this figure
that it's 500 billion pounds was wiped
off that now if you read the small print
of this article it gets quite techy but
they basically tell us that it's because
there was a type of
um over leveraged derivative which was a
bit too in Vogue and meant Pension funds
were too Overexposed to parts of the
market and I should also reassure
viewers because it doesn't say anything
in this story that people's individual
pension pots will be at risk but what we
do know is that that overall value of
Pension funds has plummeted this year
um which is obviously a huge problem for
us and our economy and they'll be
wanting to claw back that money with
safer investments in the future yes
um yeah it's all it's all it's all scary
stuff at that point wasn't it of course
the bank of England to step in as we
remember and you might argue led to the
downfall of quasi-quarting and then Liz
trust but anyway um Daily Mail quickly
um 30 000 parking tickets every day
um is it Cowboys or is it ways local
authorities due to claw back some money
Kevin
yeah they don't make clear on this but
there's a lot of figures there in the in
the mail uh 30 000 a day one every three
seconds two point seven million between
April and June reckon it's gonna raise
um one billion governments dropped uh a
plan to have a code of uh practice which
you said would tackle Cowboys and reduce
the uh maximum charge from 100 to 150
and not allow them to put debt
collectors on you but under a legal
challenge or threat a legal challenges
but it's backed off I mean that's a big
figure 30 000 a day parking tickets
until you think in the UK there are more
than 30 million vehicles on the roads I
think it's 32 million Vehicles so if I
just do my quick mental maths I would
have thought that means what one in a
thousand uh or so Vehicles get a ticket
that means if you've got something
you're probably not not going to get
what a ticket for three years I know
some people will get more but um I think
you always have to put these figures in
the context which they uh which I don't
think the male have there yeah good good
sums let's stay with some
oh yeah it's too late too late sorry it
came out of my mouth
um now then diggle Village Association
has dug in a Christmas tree and it's
cost quite a lot of money okay tell us
more
this is our classic of the genre the
Metro Off the Mark you know get your
photos in of rubbish Town Hall Christmas
trees look at that pathetic isn't it I
have to say I already tried to buy my
Christmas tree but they're not really on
the market yet I was a bit early
um but yeah this is your classic story
of town halls that fork out lots of
money and it turns out their Christmas
trees are rubbish you always get ones
don't they where um there's lots of they
put a tree up and then they barricade it
so no one can get near it wonky lights
Scrooge Town Hall bosses that don't turn
up to pick on the lies I certainly am
excited about reading many more
I think we will but if you were going to
dig in a tree you might choose a better
example than this don't you think
although I quite like absolutely you
know an odd one but anyway
I like for money and get it
November Kate yeah we'll see you later
thank you both very much indeed